>> The kinds of model we can build with scikit-learn are
rooted in statistics and regression-based mathematics.
This so-called classical machine learning techniques are
very powerful and relatively easy to implement.
So it's no surprise that they're used in
many cutting edge AI solutions.
However, when it comes to computer vision,
there are some limitations that you should be aware of.
First, the algorithms used to separate the image pixel arrays into
classes are very susceptible to variations in color,
contrast, lighting conditions, and so on.
Then, you can mitigate this by
equalizing and otherwise preparing the images,
but that can require a lot of work.
A more difficult problem is that classical machine learning
techniques apply to the entire array of pixel values.
Now, only some of these pixels actually
describe features of the object you're trying to classify.
The classical algorithms can be heavily influenced by
background pixels that have
little or no bearing on the class of object.